>> THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>>> MEMBERS OF THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE SAY THEY ARE READY TO
PUSH BACK HARD ON WITNESSES WHO
DEFY SUBPOENAS.
LAST THURSDAY MARKED THE
DEADLINE FOR FOUR FORMER TRUMP
OFFICIALS TO PRODUCE MATERIALS.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
MARK MEADOWS AND KASH PATEL ARE
ENGAGING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
BUT AN ATTORNEY FOR STEVE BANNON
SAID HE WILL NOT COOPERATE,
CITING FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CLAIM OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
STRANGE PLAN BECAUSE BANNON LEFT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LONG
BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
ONE DEMOCRAT ON THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED BANNON COULD BE JAILED
SAYING, QUOTE, HE'S COMPLETELY
EXPOSED.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MEMBER OF
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF,
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "MIDNIGHT
IN WASHINGTON: HOW WE ALMOST
LOST OUR DEMOCRACY AND STILL
COULD."
CHAIRMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE GET TO THE
BOOK.
WE JUST MENTIONED THE COMMITTEE
HAS SAID THEY ARE ENGAGING,
ENGAGING WITH MARK MEADOWS AND
KASH PATEL.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, EXACTLY?
>> I CAN'T GO INTO THE
COMMUNICATIONS, BUT WE HAVE
ENGAGED WITH LAWYERS THAT ARE
REPRESENTING THEM TO TRY TO
SECURE THEIR TESTIMONY.
BUT ALSO TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THOSE WHO DON'T COOPERATE
WITH OUR COMMITTEE ARE GOING TO
BE THE SUBJECT OF CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT, WE WILL VOTE ON IT IN
THE HOUSE, AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, AND WE WILL REFER TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR
PROSECUTION.
SO WE'RE NOT FOOLING AROUND.
WE EXPECT PEOPLE TO FULFILL
THEIR LAWFUL DUTIES.
IF THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS RAISED, WE'LL ANSWER
THEM, RESPOND TO THEM, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE PROVIDE ALL THIS
INFORMATION TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THESE FOUR WITNESSES
IN PARTICULAR ARE REALLY IN A
POSITION TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS DOING WHAT THE
RESPONSE WAS LIKE, WHY WE
WEREN'T BETTER PREPARED, AND THE
ROLE OF THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THIS ATTACK ON THE U.S. CAPITOL.
>> SO ENGAGING WITH MEADOWS AND
PATEL, NO MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT.
STEVE BANNON, HIS TEAM HAS SAID
HE'S NOT COOPERATING, HE'S NOT
COMING.
SO HAVE YOU ALREADY STARTED
DRAFTING THE CRIMINAL REFERRAL?
>> I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT, BUT
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT I THINK IS
GOING ON WITH STEVE BANNON.
THIS IS ONE THING I WRITE ABOUT
IN THE BOOK.
DURING THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION,
LED AT THE TIME BY A CHAIRMAN
DEVIN NUNES, REPUBLICAN, WE
SUBPOENAED BANNON.
AND HE CAME IN WITH 25 QUESTIONS
THAT WERE WRITTEN OUT FOR HIM BY
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND SAID THESE ARE THE ONLY
QUESTIONS I'M GOING TO ASK.
I'M GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO ASK
AND I'VE WRITTEN OUT THE ANSWERS
AND THE ANSWER TO EACH IS NO.
AND THE REPUBLICANS ALLOWED
THAT.
AND BANNON KNEW HE COULD GET WAY
WITH THAT BECAUSE REPUBLICANS
WOULD ALLOW THAT KIND OF
OBFUSCATION, BUT THEY KNEW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BILL BARR,
BEFORE HIM JEFF SESSIONS,
NEITHER OF THEM WOULD ENFORCE
THE LAW.
THEY WOULD BOTH SUPPORT AND
PROTECT AND COVER UP FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT'S NOT THE SITUATION
ANYMORE.
WE HAVE A NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL.
A NEW JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DEDICATED TO THE PRINCIPLE THAT
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
SO BANNON IS IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SITUATION NOW.
I AGREE WITH JAMIE RASKIN, HE'S
EXPOSED.
>> LOOK, IT WILL TAKE A REFERRAL
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, BUT
HOW CAN YOU REASSURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT
TAKING A BUTTER KNIFE TO A
GUNFIGHT HERE?
I MEAN, YOU CAN DO THE REFERRAL
THIS CAN ALL TAKE OVER A YEAR,
THERE COULD BE A NEW CONGRESS,
THIS COULD ALL JUST GO AWAY.
>> WELL, LOOK, WE HOPE AND
EXPECT THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WILL ACT WITH
EXPEDITION.
BUT THESE ARE THE TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
TOOLS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO USE THEM,
WE'RE GOING TO USE WHATEVER
TOOLS WE HAVE.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT
WILL BE A TEST OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM, OUR DEMOCRACY, AND
WHETHER WE'RE LIVING UP TO THAT
PRINCIPLE THAT NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> DAYS, WEEKS, MONTHS IN TERMS
OF WHEN THE CRIMINAL REFERRAL
WILL COME?
>> IT WILL COME VERY FAST IF
PEOPLE REFUSE TO COOPERATE, HAVE
IN BASIS FOR THEIR REFUSAL, IT
WILL COME VERY FAST.
I THINK THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
>> YOU WRITE ABOUT THE
INSURRECTION A LOT.
THERE IS AN EPISODE I HAD NOT
HEARD WHICH IS THAT DAY, WHEN IT
WAS ALL HAPPENING, YOU WERE --
THERE WAS OUTRAGE FROM YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, SOME OF
YOUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
TELLING YOU, YOU CAN'T LET THEM
SEE YOU, A REPUBLICAN MEMBER
SAID TO ME, HE'S RIGHT, ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN MEMBER SAID, I KNOW
THESE PEOPLE, I CAN TALK TO
THEM, YOU'RE IN A WHOLE
DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
THEY WERE TELLING YOU, YOU
WERE -- AND IN PARTICULAR RISK
FOR YOUR LIFE.
NOW THERE ARE THREATS AGAINST
YOU FOR SOME TIME.
IT IS DIFFERENT WHEN THERE ARE
PEOPLE POURING THROUGH THE
BUILDING, BANGING ON THE DOORS
THERE.
WHAT DID THAT MOMENT FEEL LIKE
FOR YOU?
>> IT WAS -- I THINK A HARROWING
MOMENT FOR ALL OF US.
THERE WERE PEOPLE BREAKING DOWN
THE DOOR, IT WOULDN'T BE LONG
AFTER THIS THAT ASHLI BABBITT
WOULD BE SHOT CLIMBING THROUGH
THE GRASS TO TRY TO BREAK IN.
AND I KIND OF HUNG BACK.
I THINK EVERYONE WAS REACTING
DIFFERENTLY.
THERE WAS A REAL SCRUM TO TRY TO
GET OUT THE DOORS OF THE CAPITOL
POLICE WERE TELLING US YOU NEED
TO GET OUT, YOU NEED TO GET OUT.
AND SO I WAS WAITING AND I -- MY
FIRST REACTION WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS CAME UP TO ME TO SAY
YOU CAN'T LET THEM SEE YOU WAS
TO BE TOUCHED THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT MY SAFETY, BUT
MY NEXT REACTION WAS TO THINK,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU ALL HADN'T BEEN
LYING ABOUT THE ELECTION, LET
ALONE LYING ABOUT ME FOR FOUR
YEARS, I WOULDN'T NEED TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT MY SECURITY, NONE
OF US WOULD NEED TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT IT.
IN THAT SENSE, WHAT ANGERED ME
THE MOST I THINK ABOUT THAT DAY
WERE THESE INSURRECTIONISTS IN
SUITS AND TIES WHO WERE STILL
EVEN AFTER THE BLOODY
INSURRECTION, AFTER ALL THE
SHATTERED GLASS AND THE DEATH OF
THAT DAY, WERE BACK ON HOUSE
FLOOR TRYING TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
>> YOU'RE SAYING
INSURRECTIONISTS IN SUITS AND
TIES.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS?
>> I AM.
UNLIKE THOSE PEOPLE CLIMBING
OUTSIDE THE BUILDING, THEY KNEW
IT WAS A LIE.
THE TRUE BELIEVERS WERE OUT
THERE ATTACKING THE BUILDING.
BUT INSIDE THE CHAMBER, MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES KNOW IT IS
A BIG LIE.
WHEN STEVE SCALISE APPEARS ON TV
AND CAN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHETHER THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN,
IT IS NOT BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
KNOW THE ANSWER, IT IS BECAUSE
LIKE ALL OF THE GOP LEADERSHIP
RIGHT NOW IN THE CONGRESS THEY
ARE DEATHLY AFRAID OF CROSSING
DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT IS WHAT HAS OUR
DEMOCRACY SO FRAGILE.
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT LIVING UP TO
THEIR OATH OF OFFICE.
>> IS KEVIN McCARTHY AN
INSURRECTIONIST IN A SUIT AND
TIE?
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY.
KEVIN McCARTHY, I TALK ABOUT IN
THE BOOK, SOMEONE WHO HAD A
PRIVATE CONFERENCE WITH YEARS
AGO, WENT TO THE PRESS,
COMPLETELY MISREPRESENTED IT AND
I CONFRONTED HIM ABOUT IT ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR AND HE SAYS TO ME, I
SAID, KEVIN, YOU KNOW I SAID THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT YOU TOLD
THE PRESS, HE SAYS, YEAH, I
KNOW, ADAM.
BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT GOES.
AND THAT'S HOW HE OPERATES.
AND THIS TO ME IS ONE OF THE
MOST CORROSIVE THINGS OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY, WHICH IS THE
RELENTLESS ATTACK ON THE TRUTH.
THE IDEA THAT THEY'RE ALL
ENTITLED TO THEIR OWN ALTERNATE
FACTS.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IF KEVIN
McCARTHY BECOMES SPEAKER?
>> DISASTER BECAUSE HE WILL DO
ANYTHING THAT DONALD TRUMP TELLS
HIM.
AND WE CANNOT HAVE SOMEONE WITH
ABSOLUTELY NO REVERENCE FOR THE
TRUTH, NO WILLINGNESS TO UPHOLD
HIS OATH IN THAT POSITION, IN
LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T NEED TO BE
APPOINTED SPEAKER IF KEVIN
McCARTHY IS BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY
DONALD TRUMP WILL CONTROL
WHATEVER HE DOES.
>> THE TITLE OF YOUR BOOK IS HOW
WE ALMOST LOST OUR DEMOCRACY AND
STILL COULD.
BUT HASN'T A LOT ALREADY BEEN
LOST?
ISN'T IT ON THE WAY TO BEING
LOST IF EVERYTHING GOES AS YOU
FEAR IT MIGHT AND AS IT LOOKS
LIKE IT MIGHT?
>> I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE ONE THING I
WANTED TO DO IN THE BOOK AS WELL
IS SHOW PEOPLE THE STORIES OF
COURAGE OF THIS PERIOD.
A HISTORIAN ONCE SAID POWER
DOESN'T CORRUPT AS MUCH AS IT
REVEALS.
IT REVEALED KEVIN McCARTHY AND
STEVE SCALISES AND OTHERS, IT
ALSO REVEALED PEOPLE OF GREAT
COURAGE.
LIZ CHENEY, OF GREAT COURAGE.
IT REVEALED ADAM KINZINGER TO
HAVE GREAT COURAGE.
IT REVEALED DAN COATS AND MITT
ROMNEY AND ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE
OF CONVICTION, WHO ROSE TO THE
OCCASION, AND, YOU KNOW, LOOKING
AT THOSE STORIES OUGHT TO GIVE
US INSPIRATION.
ALL OF US RIGHT NOW HAVE A ROLE
TO PLAY IN THE SAVING OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WE CAN'T ALL BE MARIE YAVONOVICH
WHO DEFIED A PRESIDENT AND CAME
AND TOLD THE TRUTH.
WE CAN'T ALL BE IN HER POSITION,
BUT WE CAN IN OUR OWN WAY PLAY A
ROLE IN SAVING OUR DEMOCRACY
WHEN IT IS AT MAXI